et qui sont les vrais extrémistes les
extrémistes c'est ce qu'ils pensent
qu'on peut continuer comme si de rien
n'était comme si nous n'étions pas
depuis que je me suis depuis 16 mois
nous ne battrons pas un record de
chaleur ça fait 16 mois que la chaîne
des températures moyennes et supérieures
aux normales il était depuis cinq à six
ans il ya plus d'eau dans les nappes
phréatiques
moi je le change me balade dans les
forêts vosgiennes ce que je suis chaud
alsacien je vois des arbres morts et
notamment les sapins les sapins n'aime
pas la chaleur n'aime pas le manque
d'eau des sapins meurent parce que à
cause de la sécheresse et du changement
climatique en série tout est en train de
changer notre société à cause de votre
société est en train de mourir notre
société sent le sapin très bonne pub
shine a pas de nicolas phalempin en
deuxième mi temps rien aux arrêts rien
ne va plus et si l'on continue au centre
âgé de quelques dizaines d'années
l'été les températures vont exploser la
productivité ali alimentaire qui est
cher à monsieur va au tour décliné parce
que les soldes donc à faire pousser de
la nourriture mais il y aura de moins en
moins d'eau en été
non mais mon cher nicolas je vais vous
expliquer une chose mais la vente en
lice quand les gens entendent cette
histoire de sapins de noël ou qu'ils
entendent le maire de lyon dire que le
tour de france est machiste et polluants
vous obtenez exactement l'effet inverse
c'est à dire que les gens retournent
l'écologie pour un pour un motif
d'ailleurs assez anciens à savoir qui
vous traitent d'ayatollahs verts et qui
pensent que c'est une écologie punitive
vous n'essayez pas de recueillir
l'adhésion des gens voulaient punissez
il faut supprimer le tour de france
il faut supprimer les arbres de noël
demain je sais pas ce que vous
proposerez de supprimer les gens
rejettent
et comme ce sont des divertissements
populaires que vous proposer de
supprimer le tour de france ou de sapin
de noël les gens disent voilà les verts
les écolos c'est un parti de bobos
urbains sur le principe on en arrive à
cette conclusion le prince et vous avez
vous avez raison eric très bien enfin je
dois le reconnaître il ya un déficit
effectivement de de pédagogie
d'accompagnement au changement il ya
plutôt un excès de conneries qu'un
déficit doit la logique des malades des
maladresses
et pourtant on dit que la situation est
urgente qui auraient quand même
réfléchir à un moyen de faire passer le
message qu'ont voulu mais parce que
populaire et gratuit et ça renforce
l'idée aussi que l'écologie est donc un
truc 2 privilégié et c'est quand même
c'est quand même extrêmement grave parce
que tout ce que vous dites là on l'avait
entendu mais vous comprenez que c'est
plausible à partir de là partir d'assez
podium on supprime des choses gratuites
et à la place
alors certes comme le dit rokhaya on
propose autre chose et tout mais on
n'entend même plus qu'on propose autre
chose puisque c'est dans un brouhaha
dire vous créez vous même un bois et
ensuite vous révolter contre ce qui
répond mais c'est quand même au départ
c'est la fée la poule il ya quelque
chose de précis c'est vous qui le qui
lançait ça il faut se questionner aussi
sur la cohérence de vos propos moi je ne
comprends pas qu'avec il ce qu'il parle
de l'arbre de noël qui est cher très
cher à tous les français et que d'un
autre côté il ne fasse rien d'autre par
exemple dans le cadre de sa mairie qui
l'a bien des meubles il ya des plans
qu'il ya un tas de chose qu'est ce qui
fait pour contre les choses monsieur vie
je montre monsieur sais pas vous hein
hurricanes ont réclamé bien sûr le maire
de bordeaux vit comme un homme normal
qui consomment normalement autant qu'un
être humain autres normal vous aussi
monsieur ça se voit comme vous êtes vêtu
vous n'êtes pas en train de faire une
économie de vêtements et ces gens ne te
ferait que je n'habite comme un ami ch
non mais je puis vous en voulez la
vérité
non mais je ne suis ni ya un moment il
était sympa excusez-moi emmerder les
français de sapins de noël et vous vivre
comme des gens qui consomme zéro
outrance à mourir on attend de voir
monsieur le maire s'il ne prend pas sa
voiture comment êtes vous venu je suis
venu en train on m'a proposé d'accord
mais consolez vous avez polluer la
planète donc voilà c'est pas normal vous
n'êtes pas logique pas d'interruption de
changer sa manière de faire non nous
vous viviez en des lorrains